Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour.
Merci d'être venus si nombreux
m'accueillir à l'aéroport.
En plus, ça tombe bien :
j'ai pas mal de bagages,
vous allez pouvoir m'aider.
Mais bon,
visiblement, on n'est pas
à l'aéroport de Denver là.
On est bien à l'université de Savoie ?
C'est donc une tout autre aventure
que nous allons vivre ensemble.
Êtes-vous prêts à embarquer ?
(Rit)
J'ai apporté avec moi
quelques petits bagages.
Un petit doudou,
parce qu'évidemment,
quand on se déplace,
il faut amener un peu la famille,
de l'enfance, de nos valeurs.
Avec -
J'ai amené aussi
quelques restes de mon éducation
et de mes études :
la bible de la gestion de production
notamment,
édition numéro un.
Mais bon, avec tout ça,
j'ai encore pas mal de choses
dans ma valise.
J'ai un beau stock
d'expériences professionnelles
que j'ai pu valoriser par deux VAE.
La VAE...
V A E...
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Un vélo à assistance électrique ?
Un voyage avec escale ?
Non. La VAE, c'est la validation
des acquis de l'expérience.
C'est une procédure qui existe
depuis 2002 en France
et qui vous permet d'acquérir
tout ou partie d'un diplôme.
C'est un processus que vous pouvez
enclencher à l'Université de Savoie
avec une équipe qui est dédiée
et qui va vous accompagner.
La VAE,
c'est un processus
qui est long et difficile.
Moi aujourd'hui,
ici parmi vous, c'est
comme si j'avais 20 ans.
20 ans, je vais bientôt passer
mon DUT QLIO -
enfin, ça s'appelait OGP à l'époque -
je n'ai pas vraiment envie
de poursuivre mes études,
je suis pressée de m'installer,
de pouvoir m'acheter une voiture neuve,
et de prendre un chat.
Autant dire,
pas vraiment envie
de poursuivre à l'école.
Du coup, j'ai commencé à travailler
comme technicienne en lancement.
Après, j'ai été responsable de service,
et puis, plus récemment donc,
chef de projet en gestion industrielle.
J'ai connu pas mal d'emplois différents
et pas mal d'activités, de domaines,
comme l'informatique industrielle,
le décolletage ou l'ameublement.
Et c'est au cours de ces processus,
et notamment en donnant des cours
à des élèves de licence pro
que je me suis dit : « Pourquoi ne pas
valider tes acquis de l'expérience ? »
Je vous disais en introduction
que c'est une procédure
qui peut être longue et difficile,
mais sincèrement,
ça vaut le coup de le faire.
D'ailleurs, moi, j'en ai fait deux,
comme quoi tout est possible.
Quand vous allez enclencher
une procédure de VAE,
vous allez faire un CV détaillé
qui fait quatre pages,
vous allez y joindre
une lettre de motivation
et vous allez envoyer tout ça
au département dans lequel
vous voulez acquérir le diplôme.
Une fois que vous avez eu
l'avis pédagogique favorable,
vous pouvez enclencher cette procédure.
Pour moi, ça a consisté
à réunir pas mal de preuves
de tout ce que j'avais pu réaliser,
des compétences que j'avais mobilisées
dans les différents emplois occupés.
On peut mettre dans ce processus
toutes les expériences,
qu'elles soient positives ou négatives.
On sait très bien que
même la pire des expériences
peut être valorisée positivement.
Je vous prends un exemple.
Moi, j'étais caissière
pour financer mes études.
Pour la VAE,
j'ai dû ressortir
un petit rapport de stage
que j'avais fait à l'époque en 1990,
donc un autre siècle.
Je suis allée au grenier, chez mes
parents, récupérer ce rapport de stage.
Et donc il a permis d'alimenter aussi
ce travail de mémoire
et de recueil de données.
Donc vous pouvez mettre
vos expériences professionnelles,
vos expériences bénévoles -
moi, je pourrais mettre
apicultrice, archéologue,
ou alors bénévole dans les associations,
à la fête de la pomme d'Argonay notamment.
Tout est bon, tout est bon.
(Rit)
Ce que je veux vous dire,
c'est que toutes ces expériences
sont bonnes
et qu'elles vont vous permettre
de défendre votre dossier
devant un jury de professionnels
et de professeurs.
C'est eux qui vont valider finalement
si vous pouvez obtenir le diplôme
en partie ou totalement.
Et donc moi, j'ai réussi
à avoir une licence pro
et ensuite un master 1.
Aujourd'hui, à l'Université,
vous êtes en plein
processus d'apprentissage.
On va vous donner des notions théoriques
qui vont être complétées par des stages
ou des exercices pratiques.
Mais je peux vous dire une chose :
bien que vous soyez préparés,
que vous soyez mis constamment
en situation de faire,
ce que vous allez vivre
ne sera pas du tout la même chose
que ce que vous aviez prévu.
Vous allez avoir
des changements de trajectoire,
des surprises
et de l'aventure.
Comme dit Clément,
quand on sort de sa zone de confort,
eh bien, on progresse.
Prenons un exemple :
savoir nager.
Alors savoir nager, savoir nager...
Savoir nager,
quand on est savoyarde comme moi,
ça consiste à aller à la piscine,
faire trois bulles dans le petit bain,
et puis après, on nous jette
dans le grand bain,
avec au loin la perche inaccessible.
Toujours est-il que,
quand on est savoyard,
on ne nage que dans le lac,
et la plupart du temps, enfin moi,
personnellement, dès que
je n'ai pas pied, je prends un pédalo,
c'est beaucoup plus pratique.
(Rit)
Toujours est-il que
j'aurais pu rester dans la piscine
ou au bord du lac, tranquillement.
Eh bien, comme Clément,
je suis sortie de ma zone de confort
et j'ai eu l'occasion exceptionnellement
d'aller à un comptage de baleines
à la Réunion.
Effectivement,
rien ne me préparait,
dès ma mise à l'eau,
à tomber sur un beau mâle de neuf mètres,
qui s'est dit :
« Une Savoyarde, c'est la
première fois que j'en vois une,
il faut que je me précipite sur elle.
En plus, elle a peur où elle n'a pas pied,
donc on va essayer de la sauver. »
C'est la vraie baleine que j'ai vue sauf
que ce n'est pas moi qui ai pris la photo.
Forcément, j'étais en train
d'arracher la main du moniteur
qui était avec moi dans l'eau.
Tout ça pour vous dire
que vous avez le choix.
Vous avez toujours le choix
de rester dans un système
scolaire universitaire classique,
d'enchaîner les diplômes
et d'acquérir finalement votre
expérience par un cursus normal.
Mais vous pouvez aussi choisir,
comme moi,
d'apprendre à vous servir
d'un masque et un tuba,
choses que je ne connaissais pas
avant d'aller voir la baleine.
Autant dire que
ce n'est pas fait pour moi.
La vie donc vous offrira
de belles occasions également
d'acquérir des expériences.
Du coup, la VAE,
qu'est-ce que ça a changé
pour moi en définitive ?
Eh bien, à la maison déjà,
ça m'a enlevé quelques corvées de machines
puisque je disais :
« Ben, je suis la plus diplômée. »
Maintenant, c'est trop tard : ma fille
est ingénieur, ça ne marche plus...
(Rit)
Et plus sérieusement,
ça m'a permis de m'étalonner
par rapport, justement,
aux nouveaux embauchés
qui arrivent dans l'entreprise.
Ça me permet
d'avoir une certaine légitimité
par rapport à toutes
les missions que j'occupe
dans mes postes différents.
Ça donne aussi une certaine liberté
puisque je suis libre
de rester dans mon territoire
ou d'aller ailleurs
et de passer la frontière.
J'ai pas mal de visas,
j'ai tamponné pas mal
de destinations avec ces VAE,
et donc tout est ouvert.
Voilà, tout ça pour vous dire que,
effectivement, la VAE m'a permis
de progresser
et finalement de prendre du recul
et d'avoir une certaine liberté.
Vous verrez : dans la vie,
il ne suffit pas d'apprendre
et après d'aller travailler,
il faudra apprendre à apprendre
tout au long de votre processus,
de votre carrière
et prenez conscience que
tout cela sera bon à prendre.
Aujourd'hui,
ici dans cet amphi,
vous êtes donc en plein processus,
vous êtes en attente de visa,
vous allez bientôt finir vos études,
vous allez travailler,
et je parle aussi pour ceux
qui sont victimes de surbooking,
de changements d'escale ou qui se
sont carrément trompés à l'embarquement,
ne vous en faites pas,
même si vous refaites la queue,
prenez conscience que ce que
vous allez vivre jour après jour
fera de vous votre richesse
et votre valeur ajoutée,
et que tout cela sera valorisable
et valorisant
par d'autres diplômes,
éventuellement si vous le souhaitez.
Voilà, je vous souhaite une bonne
journée et un bon voyage.
(Applaudissements)